the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today will be some sort of future
technologies future developments that
might not be around yet but are
interesting things to look for and if
you're interested in like researching
these kinds of things you want to make a
MNH out of this or want to make it who
knows PhD probably is a little overkill
for a lot of these things but if you're
interested in this kind of research
here's some things we'll talk about
today block / you know block filters or
committed bloom filters sharding
accumulators and UT Excel commitments
okay
so first one we'll talk about is block
filters so I don't think I ever really
talked about what a bloom filter is I'm
still not really going to explain how
they work but the basic idea the the
sort of high-level here's the prototype
here's the function prototype here's the
like interface that bloom filters have
so you make a filter from a bunch of
objects and in this case objects are
just bytes right or some string of bytes
and blue filters usually use hash
functions under the hood a lot of times
they don't use cryptographic hash
functions they can use sort of faster
functions where there may be collisions
but in this case it's not like a
security problem so you've got a bunch
of objects they might be addresses which
are 20 byte pom key hashes or your UT
exo's which you can represent as a 36
byte TX ID and out point TX ID n index
so you've got you know they're small
right so either 20 bytes 36 bytes 7
times 32 bytes you put these lists of
data objects in make a filter and you
get a filter out and the filters are
usually Killah by sometimes but the idea
is it's sort of a mix of hash functions
and then you say okay I want to match
filters usually a different person does
this and says ok I've got a filter that
someone generated and I compare it
against this object and see if there's a
hit right so I see okay that matched you
know this object match the filter or
this object did not match the filter and
this you know returns a true or false
and so what's interesting about these is
you can have false
positives so it may be that this object
was not in here was not used when
creating the filter but it still returns
true so it's sort of matching against
multiple different hash functions seeing
hey do any of these bits match and says
oh yeah this this object may have been
in this filter however there's no false
negatives so if you did put say address
a into this filter and then match this
filter against address a it would always
return true there's no way you can find
you know you there's no way you can put
something into the filter and then it
doesn't show up when you try to match
against it so this is useful for lots of
things bloom filters are definitely not
like restricted to crypto currencies or
any Bitcoin or anything like that
they're used all the time in various
databases all the time things like that
the current way they're used in Bitcoin
is for SPV filtering so we explained svv
like months ago the basic idea is I'm a
client I don't want to download and
verify the whole blockchain I want you
know someone else to do that I assume
the miners are doing the right thing I
assume the rest of the network is doing
the right thing and I just want to know
about my data so I'm not gonna download
the whole block I'm not gonna verify all
the signatures or keep aut Exocet on my
own I'm just concerned with my UT exo's
in my wallet so what I do and this
exists today you can do this you make a
bloom filter of all your UT X OS and
addresses so you say okay here's all my
addresses that I'm hoping to receive
money on I've got 20 of them 30 of them
100 of them however many although bloom
filters don't really work once you have
too many but so the idea is if you have
five addresses let's say you start a
wallet you don't have any money you're
pretty sure you don't you know you don't
know of any money yet existing but you
say okay I made five addresses I told
these addresses to people they might
have sent me money that would be nice so
you make a bloom filter of all these
addresses right so let's say you've got
okay address a a through
and you make a filter okay so so you say
I've got my filter F I then send that
filter F to a remote server so there's
the cloud there's some Bitcoin full node
out here
it receives filter F okay so this this
got filter F and it knows that this
filter F is specific to me right so it
seems that hey I'm a client I'm an SP V
client I connect to a full node and I
say hey I send a message that's called
load filter and I say hey load filter
here's my filter F only send stuff to me
that matches this filter ninety-nine you
know 99% of all the whole thing
everything going on a Bitcoin I don't
care about here's a filter and only send
me messages that match this filter and
so when it sends a transact well they
send in messages right when it sends an
in message but inventory was saying hey
I found this thing that you might be
interested in normally a full node to
another full node so like let's say
there's communication between two full
nodes these guys will talk to each other
about every transaction they see right
so if they see a transaction it's valid
it's got you know there's nothing wrong
with it they'll just send it to each
other to propagate transactions
throughout their network so they can get
mine later
however if a filter has been loaded it
says oh okay I will only send you in
messages that match this filter so if
there's a transaction that doesn't have
any of these five addresses as an output
I'm just not going to send it to you
similarly when a block comes out this is
the big one
normally blocks get propagated the same
you know I just send you the block
here we do something called a merkel
block I don't send you a regular block I
filter everything within the block and
send you only the things that match to
that filter so this is anjana generally
gets very small so the Merkel block
might just have one transaction in it
and it has the sort of Merkel proof up
to the root so the server sends only the
matching
transactions in the block which can you
know drop from a megabyte to less than a
kilobyte and then the client says oh
cool
there's a transaction where I received
money great also let me update my filter
to include this new transaction that I
received so if that gets spent later I
want to know about it even if it doesn't
send to one of these five addresses
right so if you're only matching on
addresses you can only sort of get money
but if you're matching on these UTX
zeros you can lose the money as well and
you don't want to lose money but you
sort of want to know when everyone else
thinks you lost money so this is this
works today this was implemented like
2012 ish the history behind it was the
the Android the first Android Bitcoin
wallet the ondrea's Shabak wrote it and
it didn't do this right it just
downloaded the whole block and then
threw away most of the data and only cat
it didn't it wasn't a full node and then
it didn't keep aut Exocet but it did
download everything and then they were
saying okay this is really slow we want
a decentralized way to do this kind of
thing where instead of just connecting
to a server so the other model they find
again
weeks ago was you just have some server
and you tell it the interests say hey
here's my address how much money do I
have and it sends you transactions and
you you maintain your wallet that way
this is nicer because it's decentralized
right every full node can do this and by
default if you download Bitcoin 0.6 teen
or whatever recent versions I in recent
sends like Oh point most of the versions
will will have this pot you know
capability where if a client says hey
here's a here's a bloom filter load it
your full mode will load that filter and
then every block that comes in or every
block that's requested they will match
against the filter the filter match
function calls not too heavy it involves
a bunch of hash functions it's not too
slow but it's slower than doing nothing
right it's lower than just sending it
directly ok so this is nice right you
can sync the entire chain
in way less data and having SPV security
problems it's really bad for privacy
you're sending a bloom filter right so
it's this thing that's created from your
list of addresses but in practice it's
got about the same security as just
telling them all your addresses
um right so it's sort of like oh oh I'm
sending a hash of my address instead of
my address well yeah but I know all the
addresses in existence on the Bitcoin
network I can just try to matching it
you know try to imagine stuff like that
when you do blue filters there's this
sort of false positive rate that's sort
of a knob you can you can twist and you
can say oh I'm gonna make a blue filter
where 10% of the time when you perform
this match filter for any given object
10% of the I'm gonna create a filter
where it'll just return true so I can
dial in a false positive rate so I can
say okay I'll make it 1% and then when I
get these when I get these matching
transactions from the full node yeah
I'll get an extra few transactions that
don't match my filter that they match my
filter but they don't actually match
anything I'm looking at and that will
improve my privacy right because then
the full node doesn't see what's you
know he doesn't know what's truly mine
he might in fact you don't even know
what the false positive rate is when you
receive a filter it could you know you
you don't know what the false positive
rate is you just see okay these things
match and you send them another strategy
is okay I'm a svv client i connect to a
bunch of full nodes and I can give
different filters to each one I think
the initial software did this and
because you can sort of put some
randomness into your different filters
to hope why did they do this it actually
makes it worse it actually makes it
worse because if these full nodes
collude collaborate whatever if these
full nodes share the information of the
filters it makes it easier to determine
to sort of filter out the false
positives because they'll have different
false positives because they had a
different filter and so if they
collaborate if they work together they
can say Oh
I got some false positive transactions I
did too we can filter out the ones that
one of us had as a false positive not
the other right so we can detect the
false positives we're sending to the
client so privacy is really bad there's
a paper written I think twenty thirteen
or fourteen where they basically like
broke the whole privacy argument for
this bloom filter based SPV and they
said like in practice you can get like
ninety something percent of the
addresses and you TXO as the people are
sending for the given you know the
software and their recommendations were
like yeah i don't see how you make this
work privately there's just no privacy
here it's slow for the server's so when
you're running i can see when you're
running a full node when you're running
a full node you can see here's all the
nodes that are connected to my phone
node and running downstairs most of them
are other full nodes all okay these are
not I don't know what those are those
are like not true like these all these
Oh point nine point nine nines they're
not actually nodes at all they don't
seem to ask for anything and then some
people put like their version message
they put an address hopefully someone
will send them lots of money it's not
gonna happen that's weird there's like
no SPV well bit okay bitcoin J so that's
a SP Java implementation which does
filter load and so we can look
[Music]
the fee filter but no filter load okay
so like no but well that's weird
someone's sending me lots of different
fee filter messages there's lots of
weird stuff going on in the Bitcoin
network but i weirdly don't have any STV
filter load things going on right now
which is unusual I don't know it changes
a lot too based on like so like Indus so
also you can sort of track your hourly
data usage and this is this server
basically it's only for like all this
traffic is the clients connect it you
know Bitcoin and so I'm doing like you
know I'm gig a gigabyte every hour which
is you know a lot for a home connection
but not too bad for here but like in
December everyone was interested in
Bitcoin and so you had lots of people
downloading it running it and it would
be something like 10 times this we're
just tons of people were you know
installing it downloading it getting the
whole blockchain and then probably after
losing interest deleting it but whatever
and a lot of SPV clients doing filter
loads can slow down your server it can
it can take CPU time right now yeah okay
so six percent 2% it's pretty low CPU
usage generally for Bitcoin even with
that many however many that was 30 or 40
different other nodes connecting and
downloading stuff basically this is like
receiving transactions verifying the
signatures and sending them out and
granted but this is per core right so if
I have two percent that's two percent of
a single core it's it's really not much
and then I guess the kernel is only
using one percent so even less so yeah
it's not much but when you have a lot of
SBV clients it can it can start using a
lot of CPU okay so how do we improve
this this is a new ish idea it's
actually about two years old and it was
kind of interesting who it was just a
random anonymous internet person posted
on the mailing list with like a fairly I
I think he's like email address with
some inappropriate swear word or
something anyway but
if whoever this person was just said hey
why don't we do it the other way why
don't we do it backwards and instead of
having the client create a bloom filter
and send it to the full node have the
full nodes make bloom filters from all
the transactions within a block and then
the client will just ask for that filter
the client can then perform the filter
match function on their own ut Exocet
and then if they do find a match they
request the entire block right so this
is a different model like I don't know
does it get the idea where okay so
you're a client all you do is request
filters so you say you know filter
please so you have some kind of filter
request this and then the full node just
says okay for every block in the
blockchain I'm going to create a filter
right I take all the objects in the in
the block which are basically all the
addresses used in every transaction all
the UTF so spent in every transaction I
concatenate that so there's gonna be you
know five thousand ten thousand a lot of
these objects put it into a really big
bloom filter generally bigger than the
ones used in this method because usually
a wallet won't have thousands of
addresses or thousands of UTX oh so it's
possible but in this model usually
you've got you know 20 30 maybe 100 but
in this case you're gonna have thousands
make a larger filter create the filter
and store it for each block so maybe
it's 20 kilobytes or something and maybe
in this case they're only like one
kilobyte so you have a filter and then
the node will request these filters for
every block so it's okay this block get
the filter gets we have the filter and
then perform the match the matching on
their own right so they've got the
filter they see hey does this filter
match any of my addresses so is there
anything in this block that may have
paid me or anything in this block where
my transactions may have been spent and
if they get it true they just request
the whole block it's download the whole
one megabyte block or whatever it is and
there may be false positives right so
they might be downloading
walk for no no reason they download the
whole block see there's nothing there
wait ridiculous and milepoc sighs yeah I
guess they're not gonna actually like I
don't think any any of these have
actually 32 megabyte blocks and that no
one's using them even Bitcoin now right
where the actual block usage has gone
down substantially
you've got like I don't know 500 K or
something
average now it's it's it's low
occasionally you have like lots of
little transactions saturating the
mempool and then full blocks for a few
hours but it's gone down and it's not
even at full usage so and Bitcoin cash
like yeah you've got 8 megabyte max
sighs but right and they're gonna do 32
Meg's full size but still there's actual
blocks are like 10k 20k whatever so it's
not I mean yeah but if you did have
actually 32 megabytes a false-positive
would be a big problem for a light node
because now you have to do you know
download this 32 megabyte block through
the whole thing actually there was
nothing of interest it was a false
positive okay try again but you can
download 32 Meg's it's not the end of
the world and if you're only downloading
you know one out of every hundred maybe
if you have a 1% false positive rate no
it's not too bad that's like 32 Meg's a
day or so but anyway this model is and
not only that you can request all the
filters match them and then download
from someone else the full block right
you can request a block download it from
someone else
so this full node they know you
requested all the filters they don't see
anything else other than that
and then they see another full node just
sees you requesting blocks and things
thinks nothing of it because that's
totally normal
this is a lot nicer model for privacy
because the full nodes don't learn
anything other at most they learn you
downloaded this block and not this other
block so maybe you have transactions in
this block but not this one but that's a
much bigger sort of needle in a haystack
problem we're okay here are the blocks
they used what are
commonalities between these sets of
blocks they were downloading not
impossible to maybe weed things out
right if the blocks are small and
there's only a few transactions and they
download the entire blockchain from a
single node and that node can track okay
which ones which blocks are being
downloaded what are the common
transactions or addresses in these it's
possible but it's a lot better for
privacy than the current model and a lot
better for CPU right so privacy great
great improvement this server has much
lower CPU because it can pre-compute
all the filters for every block right so
as soon as it downloads a block or a few
seconds later there's no rush compute a
bloom filter for it store it on disk
because it doesn't change and then when
everyone anyone requests it you've
already got it on disk so you just read
it off the disk send it over the network
you're done
the current model where you don't write
these two discs because they're sort of
client specific so a client connects in
sends you a bloom filter you have to
keep that in RAM and then match all the
things against this specific filter for
this specific user where's in this model
you make a filter for the block save it
you're good
um just just bless indeed yeah it's it's
because if it were the addresses like if
it were just the addresses and the UT
EXO's then would be really big it'd be
oh maybe 400 like 40% of the whole block
size so the idea of the bloom filter is
you squit you you you squish it down so
the bloom filter itself might only be
like 20k and so yeah it's got like the
use basic basic way of bloom filter will
work as you take sort of a bunch of
hashes and populate a bit filled bit
filled with them so the thing is if you
if you keep adding objects to the filter
the filter will eventually just be like
ffffff and everything will match it so
you need to sort of decide how big the
filter should be when you start creating
it madly adding objects to it
so with this you can you can get it down
to about 20k and then it'll have like a
pretty low false positive rate but not
tell you exactly what the address is in
ut EXO's work so it's a nice trade-off
to have yeah so it's I mean the the
perfect sort of easiest bloom filter
would be here's a list of all the
addresses and all the UT XO s basically
a block - the signatures which is sort
of what you can get with segments where
you say hey in seg what you can say hey
give me the block without all the
segment data because I don't I'm just
looking for things I don't want to
actually validate the signatures so if
you did that with regular like yeah it
drops it by about 50%
but the bloom filter drops it's the same
substantially more so if you did this
it'd be better lower CPU for the server
it's also harder to lie and omit things
so in the current STV model if someone
is running a client says hey here's my
bloom filter and the full node response
the full node can easily just omit
things so there was a transaction that
did hit the bloom filter and did match
and you know it address a was present
in a transaction and the full note just
doesn't send it there's there's really
nothing the client can do to detect that
kind of thing which in general is it's
not the end of the world in normal
Bitcoin usage if you don't hear about a
transaction maybe you'll hear about it
eventually the worst they can do is sort
of lie about you they say you didn't get
paid but you actually did not the worst
thing in the world
although enlightening network that can
change the middle a little bit in that
you want to know about the transactions
that potentially close the channel and
immediately respond to them so that's
that's more of a security problem with
lightning so with this it could be
harder to omit things especially if you
commit the bloom filter into the
coinbase transaction so if the if this
committed filter becomes like a
consensus rule and you say okay everyone
makes the twenty kilobyte bloom filter
everyone takes the hash of that and puts
it into like an opera turn in the coin
based transaction the way they do with
segue then it's a consensus rule then it
becomes essentially impossible for the
full notes to lie or omit anything
because you can get you can say hey I've
got the the headers give me the coin
base transaction and a Merkle proof for
it and now I've got the coinbase
transaction and now hey give me that
filter that matches this committed you
know hash in the base transaction so
that becomes you know they would have to
do they would have to do valid proof of
work to lie or omit whereas now they can
just easily omit anything they want Oh
lying also so it becomes harder to lie
because it's in a block right so so this
is operating on the block level the
current SPV does not operate on the
block level so you can get unconfirmed
transactions over the wire that match
your filter I think this is a really bad
idea I not a hundred percent sure why
they put it in but there's still people
who like it but the whole idea of SPV is
that you're verifying the proof of work
right you're verifying that the miners
validated this and you think well the
incentives are such that miners
mine invalid things they won't get paid
so if it's in a block I'll accept it as
okay for mempool transactions if it's
just an in message for a transaction
that's not in a block yet there's no SPV
security at all and it's trivial to send
an invalid transaction to an SBB client
this currently so if you say hey here's
and it's and it's not only as a trivial
but you can also try to figure out what
their addresses are and lie to them and
say that hey you just got thousands of
coins so that's the current problem with
SBB you said you say you're basically
telling the full node your addresses and
you're accepting transactions without
proof of work so the full node can say
hey here's a here's a transaction that
sends you five thousand coins to your to
address than I think you have because I
figure out your address from your filter
and it's got an input that doesn't
actually exist right so I'm just saying
I'm spending five thousand coins from
here and the from part isn't actually a
thing but since you're going to be you
know you don't know that so there's like
a let's see why - SPV is like a branch
on Bitcoin treats okay yeah so there's
there's a branch that Peter Todd made
called wide SPV I don't know quick and
dirty hack to lie to s pvwatts they came
verify amounts so yeah so you can just
sort of detect well you want to look at
it you can detect their addresses if and
then I think that one just sort of
opportunistically if it finds a match
just like multiplies the amount that
they're receiving by like a hundred and
there's no way that they can validate
that since it's in pool so this also
makes it on the block level which is
like what SPD really should be so that's
nice
downsides mainly that it's gonna be
hired network traffic for the client
right so even at low false positive
rates the entire rest of the block is
essentially a false positive right
they're like hey there's one transaction
in this block I want to get I have to
download the whole block to get it so
yeah more network traffic for the client
which is a downside but helps with
privacy so there is current development
lightning labs basically Lalo's working
on
it's called neutrino it's a variant of
this so and then hopefully something
like this will eventually get into
Bitcoin core itself and replace the
current server-side bloom filter code
hopefully but something to work on any
questions about the bloom filter stuff
cool okay okay other issue sharding
so this is mainly being worked on in the
context of etherium and it's sort of
their sort of holy grail of scalability
it's common in the database world where
you've got D data objects and servers so
in the case of Bitcoin are these block
chains you just store D times n right
every node stores all data instead store
something closer to D itself and shard
the data over all the servers so that
each server holds like D divided by n
right so if you have 10 servers and a
gigabyte have them each store 100 Meg's
and then you still got all the data of
course if they actually store exactly D
over N and you need to coordinate it so
they all store this you know their own
little shard and then if any single node
goes down well you're stuck so you don't
you know this is sort of the limit and
there's no no no no redundancy there but
you can have different result redundancy
ratings so you could say okay well any
you'd have like a race you're coding so
if any five nodes or any 20% of the
nodes disappear we're still okay
so the database world this is a wealth
cell exciting problem but in the context
of Bitcoin aetherium block chains it's
more difficult it's difficult here
because you're in this adversarial
environment where people are trying to
break your system at all times people
want to create transactions that are
invalid because they that can be worth
money invalid coin you know I can say
hey you don't know about this shard but
I'm telling you that on this shard I
have a lot of money and I'm sending it
to you so give me your house or whatever
so the idea is to split a single UT
Exocet into multiple smaller sets and
that that part is okay but you need
communication between the shards right
so you could say okay a little making
sort of a a bunch of different UT EXO
sets each node can choose their own UT
Exocet that they're keeping track of and
then you have some kind of merge mining
between the you takes off sets but you
need swaps between the shards it's kind
of an interesting thing to think of we
already have multiple multiple UT x oh
that's right so as of this morning coin
market Capcom tracks 1614 different
currencies ten thousands markets there's
supposedly 434 billion dollars going
room is this charting right like we've
sort of and and it's sort of a joke
but in a real sense it has taken
scalability pressure off of Bitcoin and
off of these any individual currency
because there's so many of them so if
you didn't have dogecoin maybe there
would be more Bitcoin transactions
right so so in the case of like GRC 20
or ERC 721 it actually is worse because
now you've got sort of multiple UT EXO
sets all being all being managed by a
single UT Exocet so like if you want to
keep track of how many I don't know
what's in the ICU 20 token if you want
to keep track of how many Pied Piper
coins there are you need to download the
entire aetherium blockchain so that's
that's sort of the opposite of sharding
in it now
any single UT Exocet you want to keep
track of you need to keep track of all
of them however in this case if I want
to keep track of my Bitcoin UT exocet I
don't need to download dogecoin so
that's great
and if people want to swap between
dogecoin and Bitcoin they can do so well
dogecoin doesn't have segwayed support
right so it's a little harder but Verte
coin like coin a lot of different coins
have fairly easy swaps but it's more
than just swaps we need like actual
funds ability between the shards because
if I can say oh I'm gonna use light coin
and I can just swap to Bitcoin whenever
I need to pay someone who accepts
Bitcoin right maybe but maybe light coin
drops in value 20% with respect to
Bitcoin and then I tried to pay and and
this is sort of getting ahead of the
real use cases of these things because
well the coin also drops 20% randomly
against whatever asset you're trying to
buy and so Bitcoin but Bitcoin does tend
to be a bit more stable than most of the
smaller market cap coins I mean again
you can sort of think that generally if
you have a bigger market capitalization
the you're gonna be you're gonna tend to
be less volatile and and we've seen that
in Bitcoin where like it still seems
ridiculously volatile right it's gone
down 50% since like January and most
currencies in the developed world don't
do that but if you actually compare it
to like like in 2011 it dropped like 95
percent in a month or two yeah
yeah so so sometimes there's a currency
that like has these like really inflated
market caps so you'll see one where they
jet you know someone makes a coin it
says okay I'm making a million coins and
I'll sell you to one who sell you one
for $100 and really I still have nine
you know all of the coins and one other
person has one of them but we can sort
of do the math and get a market cap of
100 million dollars that way
so a lot of the coins do that to sort of
inflate because it's like when market
cap is literally a it's like literally a
ranking and it even says like rank so if
you click like like yose it'll say rank
where does it say there yeah rank five
so like it's the fifth best and yeah to
what extent how many actual people hold
these things they just sort of made them
up yeah so so any but there's all sorts
of problems with this but the idea is if
you really want charting you want the
the swaps between the shards to not
really have counterparties and to
maintain the same value you want
fungibility between the charts so that
you can quickly and easily say okay well
I've got something on shard hey I'm
going to pay someone who's using shard B
and I don't want any friction I don't
want any like exchange between there so
this is hard there's a lot of cool of
research going on here and if it works
it's a real scalability improvement like
this is sort of the Holy Grail I don't
really see much in in Bitcoin they're
sort of like side chains but those
weren't really talked about as a
scalability improvement and it's mostly
the etherium crowd that are like this is
our real sort of holy grail for
scalability so it's interesting to look
at I haven't kept up I read a little bit
about their current their most recent
charting ideas so it's cool if it works
but there's a lot of sort of different
assumptions that go
ah they sort of like a lot of them hinge
on fraud proofs so the idea is you've
got say five different chains going
along and you don't validate
the other four you say I'm gonna only
validate this one there's four others
going on and if in my chain something
bad happens like a transaction with an
invalid signature gets confirmed or
transaction has more coins coming out
than going in something like that you
provide a small fraud proof you provide
a proof that says okay here you don't
need to know everything that's going on
in this chain but I'll provide enough
data to convince you that this transact
or this specific transaction is is
broken and then I try to broadcast to
the other people on those other Ford
like sub chains and then they know okay
something's going on wrong here let's
like freeze like let's not accept any
cross shard swaps from that one and then
the other you know this chain will have
to reorg so the idea is as long as you
have and and it sort of makes sense as
long as you have a sum number of people
checking it that can then broadcast it
between the different shards you can
assume that they're doing okay
or just accept that holes two years ago
so I'll assume it's okay yeah which is
probably more than you yeah so so sort
of availability and liveness are other
issues here where if in big in Bitcoin
or a theory oh well it's more of an
issue in a theory in Bitcoin there's a
lot of copies of the full set so if
you're not sure about something you you
can pretty easily get the entire
blockchain even though it's like 180
gigs and go through it there's so many
copies of it out there in aetherium a
little bit less so well there's more
full nodes but full is sort of redefined
and so it may be harder to get the full
thing and in the case of sharding if you
you know divide it too finely it may be
that you lose data and like no one has
it and then you're in real trouble okay
so that's sharding okay accumulators
this is something I'm actually looking
at I'm not gonna go into the details of
what I'm working on but accumulators in
general this is a cool this so
accumulators as I will describe are
nothing new but if you read the papers
like so one of the first papers is
called one-way accumulators in like 93
and if you read the paper a lot of the
words jump out is like hey this might be
useful for Bitcoin it's like set
membership and like time stamping and
like signature aggregate like it's got a
lot of stuff in there's like hey this
could be useful so an accumulator is
basically a cryptographic set and
there's some set operations that you can
do and then provide proofs so the
simplest well not even the simplest the
simplest would just be adding proof but
sometimes you can add sometimes you can
remove sometimes you can prove
something's in there sometimes you can
prove something's not in there and if
you can do all four that's even better
so the idea is you take an accumulator
and you add an object to it and in
general you know objects are gonna be
strings of bytes or just numbers right
and then it spits out a new accumulator
essentially it modifies the accumulator
so if you delete you say okay I've got
an accumulator and I want to delete this
object
well it'll modify in place and return a
different accumulator and then maybe I
want to prove that this object is in
this accumulator and it will return a
boolean like yep that worked or no it
didn't so the simplest example which I
think it's kind of fun composit numbers
so accumulate prime numbers so to add
multiplied to delete divide so let's say
you're a human so really if you're going
to do this you start with 1 1 it's not a
prime I guess but whatever so let's say
you've got so yeah one is not a prime so
that works so you can you can't not
prove any prime exists within that
accumulator anyway but let's say you
start with 1 and then you added 3 to the
accumulator so you multiply by 3 and you
get 3 now I want to add the number 5 to
the accumulator so I multiplied by 5 I
get 15 and now I want to add 7 to this
accumulator so I've got my accumulator
which is 15 I add the number 7 into it
and I get 105 I just multiply by 7 I get
105 so wait is it called like
fundamental theorem of arithmetic I
think that's what it's called we're like
everything's a product of primes it's
got some cool name so like you know
everything's a product of primes and
everything has a unique factorization so
105 is 3 times 5 times 7 right there's
no other ways around it
and if you want to delete you can say
okay well I'm going to leave the number
5 from this accumulator just divide now
I get 21 and then I want to prove 27 is
in there so I can say hey 7 is in this
accumulator it was added but not deleted
and I can do that right I tried to
divide 21 by 7 and it worked there I
want to divide and I want to make sure
there's no remainder I want to see that
a divided e divides evenly so I get a
true like yep fine divide 21 by 7 I get
3 3 is a regular old you know 3 is a
natural number it works so this is kind
of cool it
it's not really constant sigh oh but
this works even if you do modulo so you
could do modulo some big prime and have
just like criminality based accumulators
so there's some so anyway you get the
idea right I think in this case you can
also prove things are not in there but
this is limited different numbers anyway
but the idea is keep adding things to it
removing things from it and proving that
things are in there so there's RSA
accumulators which are some of the most
well known and that's you've got some
RSA number which is basically a product
of two large primes and the accumulator
itself is of constant size and the
proofs are also of constant size so we
call this a proof you know you're just
giving the number itself in this case so
it's efficient but the RSA accumulators
use trusted set up so the idea is you
need to find some composite number n
which is P times Q where P and Q are
prime where nobody knows P and Q or
nobody knows or you trust that the
person who does know P and Q not to
screw around with the accumulator
because the person who you know if
knowledge of people I think it's
actually knowledge P or Q will let you
create proofs that hey this is this
object is in the accumulator when really
it isn't so that's not so much fun for
Bitcoin if you need trusted set up
people people don't really like that
there's all these other accumulator I
say ideas some are one way where you
can't delete you can add things to the
accumulator but there's no way to remove
it sometimes you can batch things where
okay if I want so you could see in the
in the prime in the composite number
accumulator you could batch things where
if I add 105 to the accumulator I'm
performing one operation that
essentially adds three objects right
three five and seven some can be batched
like that some cannot some have trust
and set up some don't so there's
different trade-offs for all these
different use cases and in the case of
Bitcoin the idea of you know accumulator
would be put the UT Exocet in it or put
the STX Oh like spent trans
shanell put into it and then prove in
the case of UT EXO's prove that it's in
the accumulator or in the case of SD
EXO's prove that it's no longer in the
accumulator right provide a proof of
non-inclusion that hey it's not in this
SD Exocet so well with the SD EXO
inclusion so let's say you did it that
way you'd have headers and then you've
got this st EXO accumulator and what you
could do there is say I've got a
transaction it's got some inputs I prove
that this input exists in the headers
right I provide you an SPV proof so I
say okay at some point this this was
created right this input may be a year
ago I show you okay there's a setter
here's a merkel proof that this was in a
block so this exists then I also prove
somehow that it doesn't exist in here
right it exists but it was never spent
so now you can accept that oh okay he
gave me an STD proof he gave me a
non-inclusion to the SD Exocet proof so
I know this transaction this input still
exists and can be spent so what this
would do if you get it working you don't
need to store the UT Exocet anymore you
just store the accumulator and then
everyone provides proofs that hey I've
got these coins but so right now if you
store the UT Exocet it's a couple
gigabytes three or four gigs and when
someone sends a transaction you just
look in your UT Exocet right
so you see this input you say hey does
that exist
in my UT Exocet okay it does cool well
no Val verify the signature or verify
everything else about the transaction if
it doesn't exist in my UT Exocet I'm
like hey you're trying to spend
something that isn't there so what would
be cool is if you got rid of the UT
Exocet and only used an accumulator
because the accumulators are constant
size so even if the UT Exocet is 20
gigabytes well I've got this like 10
kilobyte accumulator thing on my hard
drive
and I just modify that in place
and now I don't need to store a zillion
gigabytes to there and I can do you know
I basically can have the same security
as a full note I'm still a full node but
I just don't store the UT Exocet I just
require either SPV proofs or SDX oh you
know different proofs from the people
trying to spend the transactions so this
is really cool
constant size the small proofs are small
sometimes the proofs are really small
and then the wallets track the proofs so
some questions proofs can be like
constant size or sometimes their login
if the proofs are and like oh then then
it's like not useful right because you
should might you might as well store the
UT excess at that point also what is n
is it the number of transactions blocks
can you a great these operations so
there's a bunch of questions there
another really big problem so I was
talking to Peter wolf who's sort of like
one of the premier researchers on
Bitcoin he had been talking to people at
Stanford about a lattice based
accumulator that did not need trusted
set up and he was very excited about it
because it was like hey there's no
trusted set up you have constant size
proofs the accumulator itself is pretty
small CPU wise it seems doable the thing
that sort of killed it was you couldn't
batch
you couldn't batch operations to the
accumulator
so you need and that and the other thing
is that we need some kind of bridge node
so the idea is normal transactions right
they just say here's my input I've got a
couple inputs I've got a couple outputs
I don't provide any proofs or anything I
just say I just point to where what I'm
spending and you look in your UT Exocet
and see if you have if it's there with
this new idea with accumulators you're
gonna have to stick proofs on so really
it's an extra data structure probably
per input is he saying hey I'm a node I
don't I run an accumulator I don't keep
the whole set so for all your inputs
please provide proofs and wallets can
maintain these proofs and and attach
them to their transactions and then the
nodes will verify them how
right now most wallets don't have these
proofs have no idea that this is a thing
right so if you're the first node to do
this and say hey I'm getting rid of my
UT Exocet I'm only going to verify
proofs that these UT exo's exist most of
the wallets won't provide those proofs
and so as a new nodes say hey I got rid
of my UT Exocet but no one's giving you
proofs okay I'm just stuck right I see a
block camp come out I can't validate it
so you're gonna need some kind of of
transition right if you start it from
scratch and say okay the responsibility
of every wallet is not just keep your
private keys and keep track of like what
you know your UT X always it's also to
keep track of a proof so that when you
want to spend it you give it to someone
else maybe you start it that way great
but if you want to transition well
you're kind of gonna need is a bridge
node and the idea of a bridge node is
you've got so here's an accumulator node
where it requires proofs here's a you
know old node that just has regular VT
exo's so when the old node attack you
know sends a transaction
this gives T X proof right so this
basically has proofs for everything like
all proofs so the bridge node can can
provide proofs you'll need one bridge
note right so if these if these
accumulator nodes talk to each other
they can send the proof so long to each
other and stuff like that the old nodes
cannot send proofs because they they
don't they're not aware of it and their
software but if you have the new nodes
you can say okay well when I receive a
transaction I verified the proofs I also
keep the proofs and give them to other
peers who want to verify them but you
need some kind of bridge between these
two networks
until everyone switches probably forever
so yeah so that the issue with the
bridge note is like well if you're an
old wall like you don't have to keep
track these proofs maybe so how much of
a problem is this and and the lattice
based accumulator that was sort of what
killed it
was that you couldn't batch operations
so every sorry and the proofs changed
that that's not the case with the sort
of silly prime number accumulator that I
showed but in this in the lattice based
one the proofs changed every time an
accumulator operation happened so every
time an ad happened your proof had to
change so you need it you didn't just
need to add something and modify the
accumulator in place you had to modify
your proofs in place as well and so if
you're a wallet and you've got three UTX
those that meant that every block you'd
have to do a couple thousand operations
right because every every block you're
gonna have a few thousand adds and a few
thousand deletes to this accumulator
every time one of those happened you'd
have to modify your proof for each of
your 3ut exos so do you know a little
ugly but doable because you've got three
UXOs you're basically three X the number
of operations set operations in the
block the bridge node on the other hand
has to keep track of something like 70
million UT X s alright that's about how
many there are right now and so since
there's no way to batch it that means
you're gonna have like maybe 10 K times
70 million every block it's just not
gonna happen so that was that what and
it's like well maybe you can sort of try
to shard the bridge knows and like this
bridge node only keeps track of this
portion of the set but it just looked
really daunting and that was why he was
sort of like yeah I I don't think this
lot is I think it's really key that the
either there's some kind of batching
operation where we can consolidate all
the operations within a single block to
one set operation for the accumulator or
try to make it so that it's easy so that
the proofs don't
have to be updated or something like
that so this is still an unsolved
problem although I'm working on a phone
way that I think might work to do this
and I don't want to like because this is
like videotape what's going on internet
stuff I don't want to like talk about it
but if you have questions we can talk
about it at UH like office hours or
something so if it works it'll be cool
although in some cases it might so in
the case of that like bridge node it was
the it was the bridge node that really
killed it because it was just like oh
you're gonna have to do billions of
operations per block but in other cases
it's like well these are you can have
accumulators that seem good but aren't
actually faster because it's like
verifying the proofs takes a long time
or something like that so it's sort of
like with the range proofs or something
like Wimble and what we're like the O of
n is great but you've got these constant
factors that in practice end up meaning
you're not actually faster right because
the decoding you TXO said well it's for
gigs
not even right it's three and a half
gigs now so in practice there's probably
a lot of cool cryptographic technologies
and you could write a whole paper and
have all these cool things and if you
actually implement it it's like well it
actually goes twice as twice as slow
it's just you think the regular also
this is super optimized one of the
biggest like sort of code engineering
things that has happened in Bitcoin core
is okay how can we make database updates
this how can you make like different
caching different like flushes to disk
and like editing leveldb itself so you
know making this UTI Exocet database
operation faster it's like a a big thing
in Bitcoin so it's pretty optimized and
even if you've got something that seems
like in computer science terms hey this
is login you know instead of n like yeah
but what about the constant factors so
so that's another issue for these this
idea okay other things I was gonna talk
well yeah so the last I'll do last one
and then we can maybe end a little early
and talk about projects you want UTF so
commitments which is somewhat in the
same region as accumulators a little bit
different idea
and this exists in some points like in
if you're in job and I was saying that
you basically have a tree of all the
different state you know all the
different contracts that exist all the
in different addresses in aetherium and
the root of that tree appears in every
block header so you can make these
proofs that the you know coins exist
based on a block header also it exists
in the etherium it doesn't exist in
Bitcoin but people have been talking
about it for years the simplest would
say take a hash of the UT Exocet and put
it in every coinbase transaction and
make that a consensus rule so that when
you line a block you have to you know
take the hash of the UT Exocet you're
aware of put it in the block so that
everyone can see it
and if everyone disagree is they're
gonna invalidate that block this is
really simple you probably want to do a
little bit fancier than this a bit more
useful well make it a instead of just
taking a linear hash of the entire UT
Exocet make it a Merkle tree right and
that way yeah sure it's it's very little
extra hashing well no wait
twice as much hashing right but anyway
to X the hashing but now you've got
these the ability to make small proofs
and then you can prove an output exists
at a given block height pretty easily
and as an SVG sea level security so
currently you can prove that a
transaction exists at a block height and
you can also prove it prove that a
transaction was consumed at a certain
block height right so if you have you
know all these different blocks 2 3 4 5
you can say hey here's a vertical proof
that transaction 1 was included in block
2 and then you can prove here okay
here's transaction 2 that consumes one
of the outputs from transaction 1 but
you can't prove just given but also you
can easily you can omit this proof right
so if you want to prove that a so at
block 6 how do I prove that the outputs
from transaction 1 still exist at block
6 you're stuck right you basically have
to go through
Oh blocks three through six and look at
the whole thing so even so with current
SPV proofs we can prove inclusion right
it's you sort of think that this is an
accumulator where you've got you know a
Merkle tree is kind of an accumulator I
can prove inclusion and then I can prove
transaction one is in block two I can
prove that transaction to destroy you
know consumes transaction one and block
five but you have to rely on me to give
you that proof honestly right if I'm
trying to cheat you and say oh yeah I've
totally still got money I can't prove
that it hasn't been deleted whereas with
a you TXO set commitment if every block
there was a total commitment to every
you TX oh I could just say hey at at
block six my output from transaction one
it's still in there well it wouldn't be
in this case but I could prove it at
block four right they say hey look
transaction one still in their block for
no longer there at block six depending
on how you construct the you TXO
commitment you may be able to provide
non-inclusion proofs which is also
really cool so for example if you had to
be a Merkle tree if it was just in order
insertion so like this is TX 1 this is T
X 2 this is TX 3
and you make a Merkle tree that way then
you cannot prove that something's not in
it right so when TX 3 gets deleted and
now TX 4 goes here TX five comes here
you can't prove the TX 3 is not there
anymore in any real way however if you
sort them so that every time so now that
like you sort them canonically so like
by hash just like greater than less than
and then the order gets all weird right
so like now TX 5 is here and TX 6 is
here because TX 5s hash is closer to 1
and stuff like that then you can prove
non-inclusion so then you can say hey TX
3 is not here because TX 3 would be
between 5 and 4 right just based on what
the hash looks like and I can show you 5
I'm gonna prove for it I can show you 4
and approve 4
I can show that these two things are
adjacent right in the tree and there's
no three there and it would be there if
it were you know if it existed it would
it be right here and I can show this not
there so then I have non-inclusion
proofs in the UT Exocet which could be
used for some kind of fraud proof so if
someone makes a transaction spending
something you can say no look here's the
last block here's the UT Exocet hash and
here's a proof that this input doesn't
exist so this must be an invalid
transaction that would be really cool
too because then you could propagate
that on the network and sort of prove
fraud so this is an idea that's been
around for a long time I think maybe the
reason it hasn't yet been implemented is
no one can really agree on exactly how
to do it a lot of people are like yeah
we should do that that would be cool
yeah you can prove that cv security so
one thing you could do with it is skip
years of initial block download say I
don't really care what happened from
2009 to 2015 I assume it was fine right
I'm gonna start my synchronization in
2016 and just synchronized the last two
years so I'll go get this UT EXO
commitment from 2000 end of 2015 I will
then not just get the commitment but
download a UT EXO snapshot from that
time and then I'll check that it you
know matches the commitment of the
committed UT Exocet hash and then I'll
just start from there and go with the
let you know and then become a you know
full node where I didn't check the first
six years or something and that's this
interesting mix of SPD security and
regular full node security where and I
think personally that's like probably
okay right you if you only verify the
last six months of signatures well if
everyone's been wrong for six months we
have bigger problems right like if
there's some erroneous transaction in
2015 and the entire networks been just
extending for like three years without
reorganize blocks right because then
then the miners have full control and
the miners can just make up transactions
and if you really just say oh well the
miners are doing the right thing then
they get a lot more power but if you say
well other people are validating it in
real time and I assume that that's the
case and I'll validate six months worth
of transactions so I'll pick up any
errors in the last six months and be
able to report them but I will assume
that after a certain amount of time
pretty sure it's meant okay everyone
else has been looking for this so that's
that's a you know slightly different
model than full nodes but in practice
not really because if you look at the
code for Bitcoin today there's a assume
valid which doesn't check signatures it
sort of has a block hash and says okay
anything before this don't stay don't
check signatures the developers
themselves have said yeah this is every
signature before here's okay so you want
to check the signatures which is a
little nicer that before they had
checkpoints where it would just not
validate anything before a certain block
cache so you sort of already have things
like that to speed up the initial
synchronization process but but a you
txo commitment would make it a lot more
sort of decentralized because right now
it's just the programmers are like well
you know this is last year everyone's
validated it let's just you know hard
code this into the code into the the
client anyway so this is an idea the
issues timing is probably one of the
biggest issues if it's consensus
critical then the miners need to put
this into their blocks and miners also
need to verify it when they get a block
and adding even like a second to
creating and verifying a block can
centralized mining a bit because the
idea is I want to be able to immediately
start mining as soon as I see a block
because like a larger miner a larger
miner doesn't need to verify the block
that just came out right because they
created it if they created a block
themselves they know it's fine
they build on top of it immediately with
zero you know zero propagation delay
zero verification tool a smaller miners
or mine are receiving that block have to
make sure it's correct before mining on
top of it so adding even a one second
creation there
vacation delay is something that like a
lot of the programmers like mmm you can
get it done in like half a second maybe
we're okay you know like we want this
functionality but not at the cost of
increasing that like that's the worst
time to add something if you can defer
it if you can say oh well you you needed
you know verify this but you can do it
after the fact or something then it's
fine so this this I've ran up against
this because I had this fun idea where
you could have aggregation or signatures
within a block and do it non
interactively and it was really cool and
I'm pretty sure it works but it added
like three seconds to block verification
so that killed that idea so one of the
issues yeah timing another issue
is it does encourage more STV level
verification or you can sort of see that
a lot of people will now use this method
to not run a full node because they're
like well I don't need and you know I
can just get these compact proofs for
all UTX O's whether inclusion or non
inclusion so why run a full node I don't
need to verify it because other people
are you don't really want to encourage
that because there's so much of that
already also the biggest is probably
there's got to be a better way to do
this
so there's all these different ideas on
how to do it and they never seem to
settle or converge on a single way so
they're the main the three main ideas
are sort of hash based you TXO sets
elliptic curve based commitments in our
essay based commitments so and and
there's a lot of overlap with
accumulators in that you're sort of you
know the UT EXO commitment could be the
sort of route or the hash of the
accumulator itself that you want to
prove that something's in there approve
that something not in there and the EC
one is the current one the SIP was
looking at but I've never made sense to
me because it's like trivially you can
provide invalid Proops really easily so
it's all trusted and but his idea as
well let's say you have a node that you
synced up and you want to sort of port
that to somewhere else you can do that
very compactly with an elliptic curve
based you txoko commitment which is cool
but you can't trust the inclusion or
non-inclusion purrs and there's like RSA
ones that also yeah so there's there
some overlap there anyway it's a pretty
cool idea it's it's it does exist in
aetherium which is just hash-based that
Joe Bono sort of explains the tree thing
they used but that doesn't provide for
non-inclusion proofs which would be fun
so yeah so this is another research area
any questions about UT EXO commitments
there's a bunch of graham Cohen's like
bit field thing have you seen that yes
so that was a really interesting case of
like in computer science terms it's o of
n but he got it so that it's actually
one bit per spent transaction output so
the idea would be maintained at a
maintained at T Exocet right so for
every transaction output ever created in
order you have just bits right so if a
transaction outputs created that's a
bite and you leave it all as zeros when
they're unspent and when they have been
spent you just set it to one and the
thing is yeah there's like 70 million
but that's if it's that well there's
more there's like hundreds of millions
but if it's bits instead of bytes that's
pretty small right it's like maybe 100
megabytes if you have 800 million
outputs ever and then you can quickly
see on your hard drive ok this this
outfit is advancement and you can like
provide proofs and stuff so the the bit
field thing was kind of an interesting
where well okay it's o of n but one bit
per object and you can sort of quickly
sort between so these are some of the
things that like I think that's it for
today right and then what's going to
talk about covenants but that's another
story
so these are some of the like current
research issues in Bitcoin blockchain
and cryptocurrency and there's lots of
other topics these are some of the big
ones I'm aware of and I know people
working on yeah there's lots of ways to
improve privacy scalability
functionality it's certainly not like
and sometimes people say
while bitcoin was made in 2009 and it's
like you know version blockchain version
1.0 and we need to make blockchain 4.0
or whatever and to some extent yeah
bitcoin is annoying to change right it's
difficult to change you got like the
idea of a bridge node and you know can't
we just start over it'd be so much
easier in some cases yes it would be
nicer to start over but that's sort of
the challenge it's like wait can we make
this system better but maintain
backwards compatibility and so in a lot
of cases like the accumulators or the
client-side bloom filter checking it's
not a fork at all right nobody has to
know there's no change the miners don't
have to change anything if you don't
know about this new change you don't
have to change anything and so they're
totally optional ways to improve some of
these things and that's like a fun
challenge right you're given the system
it's sort of like trying to improve an
airplane while it's in flight where
you're like okay I'm gonna you know make
it faster make it better while it's
lying we can't even land so yeah that
definitely makes it harder but but other
things are but what's also interesting
is that there's not that many things in
it that were that really requires
starting over from scratch so I know at
the New York City like Bitcoin core
developer meetup in March Bram Cohen who
made BitTorrent he's making his own coin
I guess now and it's kind of interesting
because usually the the Bitcoin people
don't like alt coins or are sort of wary
of them and don't invite altcoin people
to their events and stuff but Bram Cohen
like invented BitTorrent so everyone
sort of owes him in some spiritual way
like a couple thousand bucks for all the
music and movies they've downloaded
right so it's like olives for him you
know he helped us out so he comes to
these things and he was asking at the
thing in march okay asking a lot of
people if you were gonna start Bitcoin
over from scratch what would you change
you know all the people who are
programming this like four years and
dealing with all the annoying problems
in it okay
if you you know start over from scratch
what code do you change or what sort of
basic infrastructure things do you
change in the system and there weren't
that many right a lot of people like oh
you know there's a little things like Oh
get rid of the little silly op zero and
multi say get rid of this or like change
a couple these things but not a lot of
like really fundamental changes people
would want to have made some people were
saying hey maybe instead of pointing
based on TX ID be able to point like
height and index you get a lot have a
lot smaller there some different like
opcode things but what was interesting
is that it also it's a super biased
sample and it's like if you're asking
all the people who work on Bitcoin well
yeah they sort of like how Bitcoin works
or at least they've grown accustomed to
it so you might want to ask other people
if you want to sort of think out of the
box but there weren't a ton of major
changes that people wanted to admit so
it does seem that it's like a fairly
well thought out
you know base of a system that you know
and I'd say the etherium design is the
other design that's like very different
right the account based versus you TXO
base and a lot of the people work on
Bitcoin think that account based is
worse a lot of people maybe in aetherium
case think UT exobase that's worse they
they do app trade-off